now I do need a shield so I think I'm
gonna run up this way as you can see the
the world is open to me I can go any
direction that I want but I'm gonna run
up here through the grass good to know
alright so I picked up a tree branch
earlier currently it's all I have for a
weapon but you can see very quickly the
things that I can do within free branch
giving the flurry rug yeah yeah adorama
pics so imma for you to vote mocking
someone's giving them ideal for me out
of it what the own band is there you can
see both your change status changes as
well as the opponent's head and just
really see what's going on in the battle
but you're worried about two other
opponents here so you really have to
think about who's gonna fare best
against three other above exactly yeah
but look now no deaf boy you know
ethical team is in so father might date
how this actually works with how it
determines the winner so this is a
free-for-all battle but when ever one of
the trainers when the first trainer to
lose all of his or her pokemon that
signals the end of the battle
Oh